Hi, this is Steve Kaufmann and I'm,
again, and I'm really pleased to have with
me today as a guest, someone that I've
known for a long time at various sort of
meetups of language keeners Olly Richards
of storylearning.com and um hello Olly.
Hi, Steve.
Please allow me to say, first of
all, hi, if people, uh, enjoy my
videos, please subscribe, click
on the bell for notifications.
If you follow me on a podcast,
please leave a comment.
Olly.
Steve
uh, you and I have been involved in this
whole kind of internet based language
learning thing for quite a while.
And I want to go over some of the ways
in which language learning has changed.
And of course, both of us started
learning languages long before this
whole internet thing started...
how language learning has
changed, how the technology has
changed, how we've had to change.
So that's what I would like to
talk about with you if you agree.
I am at your service.
Okay.
So, uh, before we get going, tell me
a little bit about storylearning.com.
Yeah.
So storylearning is, um, my website,
my YouTube channel, and the whole
focus of what we do is that we
teach languages through stories.
And this all came about,
um, many moons ago.
Um, I mean, I've always used stories
and reading as a way to learn languages.
Um, but I never really thought about how
I could use it as a teaching vehicle.
Um, but then I had a long career
teaching languages and then I began
to actually write books of short
stories, which people really love.
And then, so I kind of developed
this concept and thought, well,
how many different ways can we
teach people through stories?
Much the same as the mini stories
at LingQ, um, uh, but now inserting
pedagogical elements as well.
Um, and so nowadays that's,
that's everything that we do.
So we make courses, we write books
and everything is about stories.
Okay.
And before we go further into that, of
course telling stories in a way, our
presence on YouTube is a form of story.
Uh, we talk about different things.
We tell stories.
And I just wanted to, I mentioned
this to you before we started
up, you know, here we are.
Uh, I've been in this business of, I
mean, I guess my first YouTube video
was, I don't know, 15 years ago.
I remember it well.
I was just thinking....
On the chair.
Yeah on the chair.
So, so then I was just thinking
here I am, you know, getting set
up for my interview with you.
And I thought I would describe
to people what I have to do.
So I have my iPad open because
that's where I communicate with you.
And you might describe what you do at
your end, but so I, I'm no longer looking
at you, even though you are there.
And I hear you through my Air Pods
because in fact, I'm recording the
video on my iPhone, which is located
about six feet away from me on a tripod.
Now the iPhone is connected into my
computer because I have my computer
open beside my iPad and plugged into my
computer is first of all, a microphone.
And second of all is a cable
that takes me back to my iPhone.
And then I use Quick Time and I use
a program on Quick Time to make sure
that I'm centered more or less centered
because I tend to be a bit sloppy in
whatever I do, but I got, I can see on
my computer screen, how I am centered,
what actually will show up in the video.
So I have to get that going, now the
audio from my iPhone because it's
six feet away, wouldn't be very good.
So I have my microphone plugged into my
computer and I use Audacity to record
the, uh, audio, and then we merged
the audio and the video files in order
to get a good quality video on audio.
So we are not at all dependent on the
connection that we have through Zoom,
because although Zoom and Skype have
improved there can be interruptions
and frozen moments and, you know,
different audio quality and so forth.
One other thing is for whatever
strange reason, every time I open
Audacity I get an error message.
So I always have to go through the
same step of quitting Audacity,
searching for it, with that...
Magnifying glass to get it up again.
And then the second time I
get into Audacity, it works.
So just some background.
Oh.
And I have three different sets of
lights here to improve the light.
So there's a whole set up process
to do these, to tell my story.
How about at your end?
That's the interesting thing about
that whole setup you've got there
is it didn't begin like that.
It's is something that's evolved
over the, over the years.
And as I say, there's so many
parallels between this and other
things in life where you just start
off, you know, your very first video.
I believe it was a web cam on your
computer with you just sitting on a chair.
And that was, that was that same for me.
Um, but then as we go,
we add more things on.
So my setup is at the moment,
so we are talking on Zoom.
That's how we're doing it.
And right now I'm looking at the
call itself into the laptop, which
nobody can see, but I can't record the
laptop because the camera is no good.
So what I do is I have my fancy DSLR
camera, which I use for my YouTube videos,
um, set up above the screen up here.
So I'm looking at the camera right now
because that's how we get a nice effect
for the audience who watches it later.
But I can't see your face.
Your face is down here and I'm
looking at the camera up here
and then linked to my camera.
I have an overhead mic, which is up here,
um, which is, which is capturing my voice.
Um, that's linked
directly into the camera.
I can see over here what's coming
up from the camera to make sure that
it's still recording and I'm centered.
And I also have two box lights up here,
one backlight and then four or five
different lights in the background, um,
to, to light it up and see if you won't
be able to see that right now, because
you're just staring at your camera.
But when do you see the final
results on YouTube, it will
hopefully look quite good.
I'm afraid that some of my
viewers are going to say, why
don't you get a set up like Olly?
Cause his is much better than yours.
So we'll see.
We're...
it's...
in any case, we continue to
evolve and, and, and language
learning continues to evolve.
Um, what do you think are
some of the major sort of
changes that have taken place?
Say...
which Was the first sort of language
that you, other than English, your first
foreign language, which was the first one?
And if you compare how, uh, you
know, the world of language learning
today to when you first started, what
have been some of the main changes?
So my first language was French
and, um, I remember working in a
cafe in London when I first, when
I first heard French around me and
thought, well, that sounds fantastic.
Let's go and learn it.
And so on my way home, I would stop by the
European bookshop, which was then in...
now it's in Gloucester road at the
time it was in Soho and I would go
back and the only way that I knew
to learn French was with textbooks
because that's what we did at school.
And so I would go down into the European
bookshop, um, in Soho and I would go
down and browse the French grammar books.
You had The Complete Merde, which
was the perennial French book,
which was there already at the time.
And then there were the Collins
books, the Teach Yourself books.
I don't, I don't remember what they
were and I would simply flick through
the grammar books until I found one
that seemed more what I might enjoy.
And then I would work
through it page by page.
Um, and, uh, and that was pretty much it.
Now, um, fast forward 20 years or so...
but subsequently you learn Spanish,
you learned Arabic, you learned
a whole bunch of languages.
Yeah.
And all of that was in the
kind of analog methods as well.
So I think because I was,
I was trained in that way.
I've always found personally that
digitizing languages robs me of attention,
which is for me as the most valuable
asset when it comes to the, any, anything.
So I've always got...
been, I've always been quite uh,
I've always preferred, you know,
pencil and paper to anything else.
The big things that have changed.
I mean, the major ways that I use
technology now would be for, uh, for
example, reading, reading Japanese,
I would read digitally always because
it's just so much faster to look
up either the, you know, the read,
the reading of a, of, of a Kanji
or the, or the meaning of a Kanji.
Um, and then obviously I use the
internet to take language lessons, to
connect with tutors and um, and just
for general, for general, I know, you
know, watch movies, all the regular
stuff really, but that's about it.
I'm not a big one for apps.
I'm a big fan of LingQ.
I use LingQ on a regular basis.
Um, but I, but I, I very much,
I very much use the internet to
connect today to speakers, to read
content, and then sometimes with a
little bit of help when it gets hard.
Right.
Uh, interesting.
I think it's true, and I agree with
you that reading on paper, uh, is
better than reading on a computer.
Uh, but there are a few conditions there.
It's better because you, there
are fewer distractions and you are
basically dealing with the words
and they're not shining at you.
And it's, it's less distracting.
However, I find that in my own case
I have to be at a certain level in
order to be able to read on paper.
Uh, so if I take an extreme example
now, of course, when I learned Chinese,
there were no computers and there was no
digital texts so it was all paper, but
nowadays learning Persian and Arabic,
I'm just not strong enough in Arabic.
I have your book by the way,
Arabic Short Stories, and I can
read them, but it's tough because
the pronunciation is not obvious.
Uh, the words that I
don't know, I don't know.
So if I can read it digitally,
I can hear the text to speech.
I can look the word up.
Um, I can see...
in some languages.
If I looked the word up, say on LingQ,
I can see a conjugating dictionary.
I get a whole bunch of additional
information, which I find useful, but
my goal is to get to a level where I can
read comfortably uh, a conventional book.
And so even in terms of say Slavic
languages, it's easier for me to read
Czech or Polish simply because the
alphabet that we're more used to is it's
just that much easier for us to read.
And even something like the Cyrillic
alphabet, which is really not that
difficult, it's still just that little
bit more of a chore than reading in the
alphabet that you're most familiar with.
Uh, the other thing is, uh, if I go back
in history, the reason we started LingQ
is because I had books at home in German
and in Spanish and there was always five,
10 words per page that I didn't know.
And I got tired of looking them up
in the dictionary, forgetting them...
and so even with those languages where
let's say that there's more than 5%
unknown words, I prefer now, even now
to read, uh, you know, digitally, uh, as
my main means of acquiring these words.
Uh, but for relaxation, even
though there are words, I don't
know, I just skip over them.
And I read them in a, in a traditional
book and I will get there by the
way, with your Arabic Short Stories.
I have no...
I have no doubt that you will.
Um, it's it's I think it's, I always
I'm left with the impression that
when you have people such as yourself,
who, who already know how they learn
languages best, and they have their
method that they've perfected over
many, many years and many languages.
Um, th th there's a very
specific set of, of conditions.
And we, you know, we kind of, we
know what we like and we, we find
ways to make, to make that work.
We don't bend to the technology.
We've got to make the technology
bend to us as, as it were.
But I think for most people, really
the, I think this is, I think about
it as a question of, of just peeling
back layers of difficulty one by one.
And I think this is why technology
is interesting in the dev, how the
development of technology is interesting
because, because I don't really know
so much about the Apple, the technology
space, because, because I just
simply don't use it so much myself.
But when you, when it comes to content
and the kind of content that people are
making, I find that very interesting.
And I think the fact that people can
create content now distributed to a wide
audience is very important because it
motivates them to do so, you know, so
I could think of any number of examples
of content creators on YouTube who are
now making content on, uh, based around
comprehensible input, for example.
So this is something that we are obviously
big proponents of and is one of, of many
different approaches to language learning,
but you've got people who are making a
ton of videos teaching french or Japanese
or Spanish with comprehensible input.
And they're using, they're using
objects, realea as it's, as it's known,
they're using whiteboards, computer
screens, they're making these...
everything that they're doing is making
the language more access, slightly
more accessible, one layer at a time.
And that's, I think where technology for
me seems to be really exciting is the
evolution of these content platforms so
that someone can be a language creator on
YouTube and then earn a living from doing
that, which means they can then make more.
And we recently, we've seen this
huge proliferation in the amounts
of useful content that's being
created and is out there for free.
Um, and that's, uh, that's kind of,
uh, a hidden, a hidden way in which
technology is, is driving things forward.
You know, not so much at the, the, the
Apple software set in the industry,
the enabling of people who are
just natural teachers to, to teach.
Uh, I agree.
And if we go into the sort of language
books section of any bookstore, whether it
be in Tokyo or London, there's a limited
number of books that can be there, even if
there's 10 different additions, you know,
Living Language and, uh, I don't know,
uh, you know, any number of, it's not
going to be a hundred, it can only be the
store can't possibly stock a hundred books
for learning these different languages,
but there's no limit on the internet.
There's no limit on YouTube.
And so different people have
different ideas of how they can
help people learn and they just put
them out to get feedback as well.
The difficulty is actually finding them.
You get that instant feedback so you
can, you can iterate very quickly.
But when it comes to books, for example,
we, we recently just published a book
of uh, Japanese short stories and it's
taken us, I think to well from when
I first raised it with the publisher,
about three years to get it out.
Um, you know, the length of time is
preposterous, really to get, to take a
book from, I mean, there was probably
only a year, a year and a half.
A year to a year and a half of actual
work, but, but when you think about
that, we have one, we basically
have one shot to get it right.
We spend a lot of time upfront and then we
put it out and we hope that it does well.
And we hope that it's useful for people.
Um, But if I were to do say, instead
of writing a book on Japanese stories
instead to say, well, I'm going
to make a YouTube channel about
Japanese in that year and a half.
I could be so much more attuned to
what the concept of people actually
like having listened to them, read
their comments, tried things out.
So it's an incredibly
powerful, um, dynamic.
It's all, it's almost like the
dynamic between a teacher and a
student, you know, that, that instant,
that feedback loop that we get.
Right.
Feed back loop is important.
And the other thing is just the
cost of getting it out there.
If you spend three years getting
your Japanese storybook out there,
you'd be hard pressed to get
10,000 people to buy that book.
I don't know what your numbers are,
but my experience would tell me
that that would be a large number.
You can get a a hundred thousand
views of a video on YouTube and that
you can make more and more videos.
And so you, you know, th the, the
economies of scale are so much better.
Um, one thing with YouTube, I'm a
great believer in YouTube, by the way,
incidentally, as you know at LingQ, we
have a browser extension where we can
automatically import YouTube videos with
the subtitles, the captions, and that...
Ah I didn't know you could do that.
That's fantastic.
Oh yeah.
I just click on it.
Uh, you know, and I'm using things
like, uh, I dunno there's this...
and that's another thing, you know,
content creation doesn't just have to
be people like yourself or  or other
people who are creating great content.
Uh, there's a Jordanian television, you
know, I follow the Jordanian television
station in Levantine Arabic, and
there was also this sort of somewhat
like a, you know, the Flintstones
type of cartoon, uh, in Jordanian,
Arabic, which has, um, uh, you know,
subtitles in both English and Arabic.
And so I can import that into LingQ.
The Arabic becomes the text, but
I cannot actually follow the video
and see the English subtitles
and then go through the text.
And of course the text is divided.
It's timestamped.
So it sentence by sentence.
I can go through listening to the cartoon
characters, say whatever they have
to say word by sentence by sentence.
Uh, but then I can also
watch that cartoon to get...
the cartoon is three minutes.
So this is content.
This is tremendous learning content.
So there is no limit to, I mean, I
could think of more examples like that
and both Netflix and YouTube, where
you can bring these things into LingQ
and use them as learning material.
In fact, a lot of the stuff that
we're now, that I'm now seeing
in both Persian and Arabic are
links to this kind of content.
So it's not in our library.
So it's not that I'm distributing it
to our members, but there was a link
there that enables the member to go and
then download it into their account.
So they are able to access
all of this, uh, content.
Uh, so I mean, yeah, it's exploding.
I have a question.
Sure.
Uh, grammar.
Um, I was thinking about grammar the
other day, and I often feel that, uh,
people are sort of taught grammar before
they have enough experience with the
language so that the grammar becomes...
it's difficult to understand what the
point is, uh, difficult to remember
these rules much less apply them.
However, I find that when I'm at a
certain level in the language, I do
want to get closer to the grammar.
I've had enough experience with
the language that I understand
the points of trying to make.
I've actually experienced it, you know,
and I feel that there is a lack of
grammar texts in the target language,
not for beginners because beginners
wouldn't be able to follow the grammatical
explanation, the language there that
they're trying to learn, but when
you're at a kind of, almost like a B1
plus almost B2 level, if there was,
um, a course in the target language
about the grammar, not too long, audio
text texts can be imported into LingQ.
Audio I can listen to in my car.
I think that would be a great resource.
Have you ever given that...
so that those are not stories.
The stories are the key, I agree with you,
uh, because the stories is sort of the
enjoyment part of getting the language
into you, getting the brain use to the
language, but we all want to be better.
We want to be more accurate
in our use of the language.
But if we could make the grammar
learning also meaningful input
in the target language, I think
that would be of great value.
Well, I mean, we do, we do almost exactly
that I'm at story learning actually.
So what we have, and you can tell
me whether this is, um, whether I'm
describing what you have in mind here.
But so we, we run these
monthly challenges.
So we have them uh they're, they are
30 days long, but basically, so what we
do is we will take, uh, a grammar point
in a language, a tricky grammar point.
So say for example, the difference
between the past tenses in Spanish,
which is a perennial problem.
And so we will write a story there's 30,
30 chapters, 30 days long based on...
which focuses heavily
on that grammar point.
And so the idea is that, um, so in this
case, you know, the two past tenses, and
so the idea is that you spend 30 days
on a daily basis reading content that
features that grammar point very heavily.
Um, and then through by, by, by, by force
or input and repetition and frequency,
um, you end up kind of developing
that natural, that natural feel.
Um, and we find it works really well
because as you said, the barrier
there really is, it's just, it's,
it's getting used to the way that that
grammar works and it's developing.
I mean, I can't tell you how often, how
often I've had this, this experience
of, um, you know, thinking that I know
the grammar of a language fairly well,
but never quite being able to use it in
speech and then going off and spending a
year, reading in the language and coming
back and suddenly finding without having
done any extra study that the grammar
just rolls off my tongue naturally, you
know, more naturally than, than before.
It's simply a question of, of exposure
over time, frequency and exposure.
I mean, there really is no...
I agree.
No other elements of it, but it kind of,
that can be quite a tough, a tough pill
to swallow for, um, for someone who's
coming at it new, because it's, it's
not, it's never the case that you can
kind of chart your development or your
progress against days or hours of study.
You know, you just have, you just
have to, you know, dive in, surround
yourself by it and then just trust
that, that we will then develop the,
the knowledge as, as, as, as you go.
Right.
Yeah.
I mean, uh, I think the brain,
we underestimate the brain, the
brain has the capacity to establish
rules, create patterns, connections.
And so I'll, after a year of
reading, you're going to naturally
use the language more correctly.
Uh, but some things you won't notice.
And so we all know people who have
lived in Britain or Canada for
30 years and still make the same
fundamental mistakes in English
that reflect their native language.
Uh, but they're still getting more...
or they've reached a certain level
that much of what they say in
English is grammatically correct.
Uh, so the brain will form patterns.
Uh, and to that extent, I agree with
you that lots of listening, reading is
going to help the brain farm patterns
that are increasingly correct, but
there are things that we don't notice.
And I think when we start into
the language, some sort of overall
description of how the language
works in English is kind of helpful.
And as long as we don't try to
remember any of it, cause we can't.
Uh, but it kind of helps us.
Although certain things are immediately
obvious, the verb comes at the end.
You almost don't need to be told that
you'll figure that out pretty quick.